the Geoghan experience okay where is
that special that I saw of you you have
a special oh yeah yeah yeah it's on
Amazon Prime
blasian that's what it's called it's
called blasian and what's crazy is it
came out probably about eight months
last time I was on here but they just
released it on DVD so my mom thinks I
made it last week on DVD at Best Buy and
Target and my mom saw it at Target
that's hilarious your mom still buys
DVDs yeah I was like who buys DVDs and
you know comedy dynamics was like yeah a
company wanted to put it out so I was
like all right cool
but what out but the main thing is I'm
gonna be in New York I got this new tour
new material I'm exhausted
that's what it's called it talks about
my two kids the family all the things
going on in the world and I'm at Gotham
comedy club
March 7th and 8th yeah yeah it's the
diapers in the bottles now man that
March it's I think it's March 7th day
I'll put the wrong date on there but
March 7th and 8th fix that [ __ ] I am I
am you put the wrong date on the [ __ ]
buyer oh my goodness the largest podcast
in the world March 7th and 8th 7th and
8th Gotham Comedy gonna try buy tickets
for the 6 they're like what maybe they
could squeeze you on 6 - no no it's my
son's birthday I gotta be there probably
why you subliminally accidentally put
that do thinking about that number oh
man I can't miss my son's brain oh of
course not
so Michael yo.com for tech beautiful so
this special that's on Amazon like why
did they release it now on DVD
they said comedy dynamics I guess
there's a DVD company that invests in a
couple specials a year and for some
reason they vested in mine and thought
it could do well so and I was like who
buys DVDs and they go oh it's about
three billion dollars a year still whoa
yeah and I'm like okay I'll but mostly
action movies and [ __ ] buys DVD people
live I don't have a damn that sucks
yeah where's that though rural America
whoo even rural America has internet not
if you have a satellite the people at
satellite you can't really stream
Netflix and stuff with satellite
unless you have really good satelite
like how good is good satelite now
that's the red box and like oh man she
told Blockbuster to hang in there
Netflix awesome that's like the original
building oh yeah we got rid of that no
no no I guarantee you that it's done oh
they got rid of I know people that do it
use it they got rid of it I get look at
are you just guessing no I know I I
thought I read an article that said they
got rid of that like five years like
three or four years ago no I have why
would look hey get the DVD get the DVD
if you want but I just don't know one
person like my mom didn't even buy my
DVD that movies delivered right to your
mailbox
free shipping no late fees is that net
yeah DVD combos DVD Netflix calm
that's crazy so mixing it in there so
the two facts they said comedy dynamic
so it's about three billion dollars a
year in Aquaman made seventeen million
dollars off of DVDs whoa
right really yes a bunch of ladies
finger blast themselves to Jason
tomorrow as this pausing it's the most
paused movie ever
they just pause it ways flexing the
movie that's the most-watched to movie
with a vibrator have you guys li 212
million DVD blu-ray and rentals account
for once only three point one point
three four percent of Netflix revenue
Wow
two point seven million subscribers as
of last year they made 212 million just
from DVDs last year and that's just
Netflix just wait winning that's just
really think that's not even owning
that's running yeah yeah there's money
you better Hey Joe you better put out a
DVD quick yeah middle America Netflix
don't want if they put my [ __ ] on DVD
I'm sure you can read a girder strange
times on DVDs I don't know yeah it's
some people are still doing it but I
think well that's one thing that I am
curious about though
what's the best satellite downloads you
can get what's the satellite download
like if you're in the middle of the
country you can get satellite internet
when the upload is terrible but the damn
thing now everybody has good internet I
launched trying to fix that problem with
yabbies filling the sky above junk
floating around up there anamur amateur
astronomers getting pissed they think
they're seeing UFOs just elan satellites
what is
[Applause]